no matter what no matter who it is if
it's the dinosaurs or the things in
jumanji i'm probably going to try and
[ __ ] one of them
[Music]
hey i'm sad volcano i'm here to answer
the internet catch me on tour
savilecountercomedy.com i'm going
everywhere in the united states right
now so check it out and check out taste
buds and hey babe my podcasts would you
rather have wet socks for a whole year
or a year-long cold holy [ __ ] okay i
gotta go wet socks oh man that's tough
that's tough will my feet start to do
that thing where they look like yeah
wrinkle up and all that stuff i live
with a year-long cold right now i have
the lowest immune system in the world
it's been that my problem forever so
honestly like i have a cold right now i
hope you're all okay with that
might be covered might not though it
might not though so i'll take wet socks
what's better being a cowboy or a pirate
uh
i've always been attracted to horses i
don't really talk about it so i would
say being a pirate because i'm afraid to
put myself on a horse so yeah pirate if
i was cowboy things might not go my way
and i don't want to be that embarrassed
would you rather be stuck in jurassic
park or jumanji like the horses i have a
thing for dinosaurs so
uh yeah there's no [ __ ] way i would
be in jurassic park i'd be in jumanji
twice on sunday over jurassic park i
don't like exactly right i don't like
bugs oh it's been a minute since i
watched jumanji so jumanji is the huge
bugs what the [ __ ] kind of questions are
these then
he said i can't win i can't win
yeah well i mean just pick one i'm gonna
die either way
no matter what no matter who it is if
it's the dinosaurs or the things in
jumanji i'm probably gonna try and [ __ ]
one of them would you rather have a chef
a masseuse or a chauffeur for the rest
of your life i would rather have a chef
i will tell you what massages you could
still get at a pretty good rate i go
down at this place on eighth street it's
like 40 for an hour you can't believe it
you feel guilty at the end of it i'm in
love with the asian woman who does it
chauffeur is fine but there's uber i
would need a chef because i need someone
to cook me healthy meals because i i
will continue to look like this if i
can't get a chef and it's delicious yeah
oh give me a chef every day this one
didn't come this one came from somebody
else uh [ __ ] marry kill chris the stuff
no joe darrow's a homeless pimp
so if you don't know these are my uh go
to the no press channel on youtube those
are my podcasts uh chris the stefano
jodorowson all right so what has to
happen here is i have to uh marry
homeless pen yeah he has a large skill
set he's younger so i die first which is
nice i don't want to die before my
partner and he has a wonderful smile
well you know i i would i would i would
probably uh [ __ ] christos stefano
um just because he has a very light
touch he has a he has a very light way
about him that really mirrors me so i
think he'd be gentle and then joe derose
is dead and i think that you guys knew
that before you even handed me this card
like you know and then nothing against
your rosie he knew he was dead even when
i got it
uh would you rather throw up anytime
someone says mcdonald's or wear a fedora
wear a fedora for the rest of your life
and if anybody asks you about it you
have to say i like the way it looks that
is
hysterical and um only two people could
wear fedoras two people uh you know
black people
and justin timberlake
and so like i'm neither of those and so
i can fedora i've never seen someone
pull off a fedora i've been in a
relationship with a girl i'm with puts
on a fedora and i'm like i just have to
be honest you're not pulling it off
you have to wear the hat you can't let
the hat wear you and for the most part
fedoras wear you and so i would throw up
anytime oh someone says mcdonald's i
thought it was any time i got mcdonald's
no i would still throw up every time i
wear mcdonald's i can't wear a fedora
would you rather never win an argument
with derosa again or always lose on
impractical jokers well i do both right
now so i've never won and i've never
i've never won either right now so it's
really i don't do any of them who has
the easier job santa claus or the easter
bunny
but i i like to give it some actual
thought
my snap judgment was the easter bunny
yeah yeah sorry sorry guys there's a lot
of likes and people staring at me this
is the tenth question i've answered and
i've already admitted to [ __ ] animals
a few times like just take it down man
okay i was at my thing as the easier
easy one it was easier
but then i don't know i want to give you
a real answer i want to think about what
goes into it you know and honestly
also the tooth fairy is really weird
people think she has it even easier than
easter bunny but she's collecting
discarded human flesh and then she's got
to dole out her own cash
and she's breaking into people's houses
in the middle of night while they sleep
i mean i know santa is but santa's going
through the tree this [ __ ] is going
under your pillow so the easter bunny is
horrific by the way like it's a it's a
man-sized bunny
that brings you chocolate and eggs none
of the things are cohesive
it's a religious holiday where a bunny
brings you an egg none of it makes sense
yeah we just accept it it's ridiculous
yeah the first time the first tooth i
ever lost them i said am i still
answering the internet the first tooth i
ever lost in my entire life i put it
under the pillow and i was excited until
i went to sleep then i started to
realize what was about to happen like i
started to realize the reality of the
situation that somewhere tonight this
woman is getting into my home she's
going to hover above me and get under my
pillow and i had a full freak out and in
that moment and if you're watching
you're a child st pause but i had i was
so scared that my mom took me to the
kitchen and she showed me the the
envelope with my tooth in it and then
the envelope with all the money that and
she admitted to me so on night one my
first lost tooth i found out the reality
of the tooth fairy because i don't know
who's making this [ __ ] up but it's
traumatizing to kill me
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child
who has the greatest voice of our
generation are you killing the kid yes
of course i'm gonna kill the kid
because at that point it's me and him
and i'm more valuable to myself than he
is to me well i feel like i could also
lend to something to society i don't
think i'm not going to be down on myself
and think that i have to kill myself so
this kid could live there's going to be
other blind kids that want to say [ __ ]
which group is worse the people who clap
during a movie or the people who clap on
an airplane lands without a doubt
airplane landing i'm just i'm already
already wound up on an airplane i hate
everybody's guts and when it's landing i
just don't want to be bothered with
anything
i guess i'm like oh god yeah well people
will clap at a movie am i guilty of it i
clapped at rocky i clapped at rocky yeah
yeah i remember yeah i caught it rocky
it's kind of fun if everyone's doing it
and you're like
derosa
[Laughter]
which of your friends do you suspect buy
speed picks
thank you thank you so much that's the
end if i've ever seen it before in my
dollar because that is the answer i
would have given
a big shout out to salvolcano thanks
babe make sure you guys are subscribed
leave a comment below on who you want to
see next and click the little bell icon
so you get all the notifications for our
new content